es ist ein absoluter albtraum für eltern
bei einem kinder fußball turnier auf
einem sportplatz im gras hausen in
rheinland-pfalz tier plötzlich ein
gewitter auf eine windhose erfasst dann
eine hüpfburg
sie springen haben spaß spielen
ausgelassen 15 kinder toben während
eines fußballturniers auf dem sportplatz
sondershausen im kreis rhein hunsrück
auf einer hüpfburg dann der schock ein
windstoß erfasst das bunte spielgerät
heißt es aus der verankerung zieht es
mehrere meter weit nach oben schleudert
das über einen zaun und über 40 meter
über eine wiese auf der hüpfburg zu
diesem zeitpunkt 15 kinder sie fallen
aus vier bis fünf metern höhe hart zu
boden neun werden verletzt fünf von
ihnen schwer wir werden sogar mit einem
rettungshubschrauber in umliegende
kliniken geflogen
ein großaufgebot von rettungskräften war
vor ort vier rettungshubschrauber mit
entsprechenden notärzten sechs
rettungswagen bodengebundenen notarzt
und diverse feuerwehr einhalten die
kinder sind fast alle in entsprechende
fach kliniken transportiert wurden
entsprechend der schwere der verletzung
mit hubschrauber oder mit
bodengebundenen rettungsmittel wie kann
so etwas passieren war die hüpfburg
eventuell nicht genug gesichert die
polizei hat die ermittlungen aufgenommen
auch die hypo wird jetzt intensiv
untersucht
und unser reporter thorsten kraemer es
ist live vor ort und uns jetzt
zugeschaltet du hast nicht zuerst die
frage wie geht es denn den kindern jetzt
heute morgen ist der stand nach wie vor
wie gestern die neuen kinder die
verletzten sind nach wie vor in
behandlung fünf davon schwer verletzt
ich habe versucht zu mit der
staatsanwaltschaft heute morgen kontakt
aufzunehmen und dann aktuellen stand
abzufragen leider habe ich keine
rückmeldung bekommen auch nicht ob
eventuell das eine oder andere kind
sogar in lebensgefahr liegt
wenn man es einmal mit was genau sich
dort hinter die er gestern abgespielt
hat das ist das absolute grauen und es
ging ganz schnell es waren zahlreiche
kinder auf der hüpfburg die dann vom
boden weggerissen wurde
ja es war gestern gegen mittag das
wetter war wie heute strahlender
sonnenschein plötzlich war die windrose
da und diese windhosen die treten
unvermittelt auf das ist ein
wetterphänomen zwischen einer kaltluft
und einer warmen luft franz plötzlich
bildet sich ein kleiner wirbelsturm ein
kleiner tornado und der reichste
natürlich alles mit sich ich hatte vor
wenigen minuten die möglichkeit mit dem
ortsvorsteher die unfallstelle genauer
anzuschauen er selbst ist ehemaliger
unfallgutachter und hat mir die
einzelnen punkte gezeigt wollte sich
aber auch nicht weiter dazu äußern weil
er natürlich den ermittlungen nicht
vorgreifen möchte aber das was ich
gesehen habe versuche ich dir jetzt
natürlich genauer zu beschreiben
es gab auf der einen seite
ein platz da ist die hüpfburg
eingezeichnet dann kurz dahinter stand
ein zelt keinen cent sondern ein tor und
dieses tor wurde dann mit der hüpfburg
und dem winddruck nach hinten gerissen
bis an den zaun zu einem weiteren tor
und dort sieht man an diese metallzaun
starke verformungen also man kann sich
nicht vorstellen welche kräfte hier
gewirkt haben müssen besonders betroffen
macht nicht natürlich auch der anblick
des zauns in ungefähr vier meter höhe
sieht man blutspuren es gibt auch
blutspuren am boden also hier sind
bereits die ersten kinder verunglückt
dann geht es weiter mit der windhose
wurde dieses zelt also diese hüpfburg
über den zaun hinweg getragen dann
siehst du jetzt hinter mir einmal auf
der linken seite den sportplatz auf der
rechten seite dann ein privathaus das
ist eine distanz von ungefähr 60 metern
und über diese entfernung ist diese
hüpfburg in der luft hinweg getragen
worden über ein carport und dann in
einem privaten garten dann zu boden
gekracht und die kinder sind aus einer
höhe von ungefähr fünf metern auch auf
den boden hart aufgekommen also die
retter hatten hier einiges zu tun und
einiges zu sehen was sie auch erstmal
verarbeiten müssen es auch
rettungshubschrauber
aus dem benachbarten luxemburg mit im
einsatz heute morgen ist der
ortsvorsteher wie gesagt hier vor ort
und schaut sich die unfallstelle genau
an seine botschaft an andere gemeinden
in deutschland ist so etwas darf sich
jetzt im sommer wo natürlich viele
familien gerne diese hüpfburgen besucher
auf den stadtfesten oder auf den
sportplatz fressen so etwas darf sich
nicht wiederholen und ich konnte mir die
unfallstelle mal genauer anschauen es
ist nur mein eigener eindruck aber dass
weitere müssen natürlich die ermittler
dann feststellen was ihr genau geschaut
nicht konnte zumindest keine löcher im
boden 10 befestigen
vielen seinen thorsten für deine
einschätzung und ja auch erläuterungen
an den moment dankeschön